a new report says Harvey Weinstein used
a so-called army of spies to block the
reporting of sexual misconduct
allegations against him The New Yorker
reports that the disgraced Hollywood
producer used a team of lawyers private
investigators and former Israeli
intelligence officers according to the
magazine the goal was to subvert and
intimidate his accusers Jericka Duncan
is here with details from the new report
Jericho good morning good morning Nora
as sexual harassment and assault
allegations against the former movie
mogul continue to mount this new report
provides insight into how Weinstein
allegedly monitored a number of private
security firm investigations into his
accusers in the fall of 2016
nearly a year before any allegations
against Harvey Weinstein had surfaced he
allegedly initiated what The New Yorker
calls a concerted effort to silence his
accusers in a new report the magazine
claims Weinstein enlisted the help of a
quote army of spies to track actresses
and journalists attempting to publicize
allegations against him the article
describes tactics to allegedly gather
information in one example a private
investigator is said to have posed as a
woman's rights activist in a meeting
with actress Rose McGowan McGowan would
later accuse Weinstein of rape The New
Yorker says that investigator was an
employee of black cube an investigative
firm run largely by former Israeli
intelligence officers the work by black
cube was allegedly run through one of
Weinstein's lawyer's high-powered
attorney David Boyce who famously
represented Al Gore in the 2000 Supreme
Court election dispute in a contract
between voices law firm in black cube
The New Yorker report says it directed
black cube to help expose information
that would stop the publication of a New
York Times story about Weinstein's
abuses over a year-long period
Weinstein's team of investigators
allegedly collected intelligence on
dozens of people including psychological
profiles that The New Yorker says
focused on personal or sexual histories
David Boyce told The New Yorker we
should not have been contracting with
and paying and
two Gators that we did not select and
direct Harvey Weinstein's spokesman said
it is a fiction to suggest that any
individuals were targeted or suppressed
at any time and in a statement to CBS
News black cube said it has a policy to
never discuss its clients with any third
party and it operates in full compliance
with the law of any jurisdiction in
which it operates scale all right the
plot continues Thank You Jerrica